nobody wants to see super Mario's nose
hair
video games are about to look even more
realistic thanks to separable subsurface
scattering or SSSs or short designed
specifically to be used for virtual
characters with human skin SSSs renders
in real time meaning that it's not just
to beautify cutting or cinematic
interest instead it's a real-time
gameplay although this technology is not
yet available in games currently on the
Shelf the project has the official
support of activism and will be
implemented in games in the near future
alright so I'm fascinated by this story
because I used to be a major video game
player I don't want to brag guys but I
used to be an assistant manager at
Electronics Boutique you may know that
as Game Stop nobody sold more Pokemon
than me and 99 denied one true story so
what gets me about this is it seems to
be like when I I can still play like a
pin in Tendo or Sega Genesis and I still
love it it reminds me of childhood are
saying when I try to play games on ps3
or xbox 9 or whatever it is it's seen it
all seems too real to me is that am I
just old and grumpy no you're I mean
you're describing what people refer to
as the uncanny valley paradox where
there's like this sort of u-shaped curve
where when we get to a certain point of
realism if it's not real enough it
starts to be a revolt
you know repulsive to us but I think
that this is really amazing technology
the fact that technology can now render
that level of realism and Realty and to
me it's just incredible so is that scary
because we all saw it I had the same
reaction when we saw that face in the
package like that looked real that
looked really real does that seem scary
to you somehow I think it's gonna be
scary when they start to apply it to
like the gore like first person killing
games when you're like killing real
people who knows what that could
encourage yeah but I do think you're
kind of an old man trying to repress the
advancement of pixelation and keep it
back in the 80s if I can get everything
to still be a bit
I repeat I would be absolutely thrilled
so all right so I know that some people
will make the argument that you're
saying that you know there's always this
idea that video games cause violence
even though from everything I've seen
there's no scientific proof that it's
true but that eventually will start
there's a difference between playing you
know doom or something from 1994 and
shooting a lot of pixelated stuff to
literally shooting things that look like
humans so and then you throw in some you
know prescription medication and it's
it's a bad combo right yeah no it's
definitely I mean it's scary but I tend
to look at the bright side of things
like this technology might bring us one
step closer to our own personal Ava from
ex machina who I'm completely in love
with it was amazing movie so I think
that word just get we're one step closer
to that yeah well you're ignoring the
question you ought to bank a robot yes
you know I'm gonna choose really sexy
you better know better yeah no coma
robot no no do you want to bang a robot
let us know in the comments right now